we're asked to draw the line of
reflection that reflects triangle ABC so
that's this blue triangle onto triangle
a prime B prime C prime which is this
red triangle right over here and they
give us a little line drawing tool in
order to draw the line of reflection so
the way I'm gonna think about it is well
when I just eyeball it they look it
looks like I'm just flipped over some
type of a horizontal line here but let's
see if we can actually construct a
horizontal line where it does actually
look like the line of reflection so
let's see C and C Prime how far apart
are they from each other so if we go one
two three four five six down so they are
six apart so let's see if we just put
this three above C Prime and three below
C let's see if this horizontal line
works as a line of reflection so C or C
prime is definitely the reflection of C
across this line C is exactly three
units above it and C prime is exactly
three units below it let's see if it
works for a and a prime a is one two
three four five units above it a prime
is one two three four five units below
it so that's looking good
now let's just check out B so B we can
see it's at the y coordinate here is
seven this line right over here is y is
equal to one and so what we would have
here is let's see this is looks like
it's six units above this line and B
prime is six units below the line so
this indeed works we've just constructed
the line of reflection that reflects the
blue triangle triangle ABC on to
triangle a prime B prime C Prime